Okay, let's go to the phones at six one seven
eight three zero.
Forty seven fifty and see what is on people's
minds.
Oh.
Let's go to Brody from Dallas, our friend
Brody from Dallas, who has written the guide
on how to call into the show.
What's going on, Brody?
Hey, David, I'm pretty good, how are you doing?
Good.
Awesome.
Hey, so I know that Bernie Sanders has asked
his supporters as.
Have you spoken on your show about the proper
direction in which to go as far as getting
our police more accountable?
Yes.
Are we safer and doing it in the right way?
The question I have for you today is when
people who see that say that, look, we've
tried voting, we've tried activism, we've
tried legislative mechanisms, we've tried
judicial mechanisms.
And now that's worked.
When people who come to you and say, hey,
David.
I think that using a mechanism like a ballot
initiative or defunding to force people to
come to the table to negotiate for a different
type of police department is the way to go.
What would your response be to that?
Well, I would reject on principle this idea
of we've tried it.
There has not been.
I mean, listen, when you're talking about
police departments, this has to do primarily
with with three things.
It has to do with police chiefs who are in
most places appointed by mayors.
So where have been the big movements to hold
mayors accountable for who has been selected
as police chief?
I mean, I'm sure we can find some examples,
but there's been no major movement to say,
elect, let's put in place the right mayors,
make police chiefs selection and police policy
a huge part of those mayoral campaigns.
I've been involved from the media side in
a bunch of different mayoral races, and it's
just it's just never been a thing.
So then you've also got to look at governors
because a lot of funding for police is state
funding for both state and local police.
We finally heard from Andrew Cuomo with some
ultimatums when it when it comes to police.
But I would just reject the idea that we've,
quote, tried it.
Now, if we reject the idea that we have tried
it, would that mean that if there is a ballot
initiative or a push for a ballot initiative,
such as one that, for example, is coming up
where I am and the area in Fort Worth to restrict
a portion of the funding that goes to SWAT
and things like that?
Would you support a bet that ballot initiative
which is on the ballot?
And I don't mean would you support it one
way or the other?
Would you support letting voters have a say?
Oh, yeah, of course.
I mean, so there is a question as to whether
you want to vote on civil rights.
Right.
So when we talk about, hey, should gay marriage
be legal, I am skeptical about letting people
vote on those things.
And people have voted the wrong way when it
comes to how tax money should be used.
I am very much, as a general rule in favor
of letting the people have a say.
So while I don't think defund the police is
the solution.
If the public has said we want this on the
ballot, then of course that that it should
be on the ballot.
Absolutely.
Are there any other mechanisms that you would
suggest in terms of besides looking at governors
and who makes these appointments that people
can look at in terms of making a direct and
positive change in their community?
Yeah, I mean, I think it's getting involved.
So when you talk about lobbying city councilors,
I mean, a lot a lot of people do we have to
turn the Internet activism into actually getting
involved in a in a local way because the national
movement around this is great for energy.
But the national movement is not going to
make, you know, the Back Bay neighborhood
of Boston necessarily demand or achieve change.
So I think it's we've got to translate that
in the same way that like we've got to turn
the protests that started when Trump was elected
into voting in November.
If we want to turn it into something, we have
to take these protests and turn it into a
very, very specific and calculated local activism.
Awesome.
Hey, I hopefully I lived up to the guy that
I created for calling in and I appreciate
the information and I love the show, man.
Keep it up and things from I work it.
All right, Brody, great to hear from you.
Always great to hear from Brody.